reject hi um hi I'm miles thank you all
for taking the time today I was thinking
you know can we just give a quick round
of applause to everyone from reject
who's put on this really amazing
conference today
like well they didn't start the timer so
that didn't work as well as I hoped but
so I'm currently pretty fun employed and
between gigs it worked out really
greatly it happened right before burning
man so I had a lot of time to enjoy and
plan but don't worry I've got something
really exciting plan but I can't tell
you about it yet but so you know the
reason I mentioned what I do is a great
way to start a lot of talks is to look
at the audience and let them know hey
this is why I'm qualified to tell you
what I'm about to tell you so you know
empathy is a really interesting topic
and there is you know there's some
interesting reasons why I'm qualified to
talk to you about it so I have an
undergraduate degree in fine art I
studied some Marxism I studied some
digital technology culture some
posthumanism you know none of that
really matters to talk about empathy
though I have a master's degree in music
you know music is all about connecting
with people and all that but like you
know that doesn't really matter either
it turns out I'm qualified to talk to
about empathy because I'm a human being
and we'll get back to why that matters
later but right now you know I'm going
to give you a quick breakdown on what
we're going to talk about we're going to
give a quick definition of what empathy
is we're going to follow that up with
describing what's the difference between
empathy and sympathy those are two
things that are very very similar
they're often confused but they're also
very different and you know sympathy can
actually be pretty toxic believe it or
not we're going to talk about the
history of the term empathy where does
it come from how did it evolve it's not
as old as you think it's a little
spoiler we're going to talk about the
neuroscience of empathy how we're wired
for empathy why does this actually
happen we're going to follow that up
with about the concept of learning
empathy it turns out you know even
though we're naturally wired to be
empathetic it's not supernatural to
follow through on that then we're going
to talk about empathy as a developer
really short we're not going to really
focus on that too much but we'll start
with this definition there's a fantastic
paper by Teresa Wiseman defining the
attributes of empathy she's a nurse this
paper is specifically focused on nursing
but she studied many professions and I
think you know it's a pretty global
thing
so the first thing about being
empathetic is understanding the
perspective of the person in which
you're being empathetic to it's
important to stay out of judgment it's
really easy to judge an individual you
can't do that if you're going to
empathize you need to recognize what
they're feeling you need to figure out
that feeling you need to separate it and
you need to really understand it and you
need to follow up by communicating back
to the individual what that feeling is
empathy is feeling with people so
Theresa Wiseman have this great quote in
our paper it is the ability to empathize
which distinguishes an average nurse
from an excellent nurse and the eyes of
the patient so I'm going to go and just
you know step out and say hey perhaps it
is the ability to empathize that
distinguishes an average developer from
an excellent developer in the eyes of
others and then you know maybe even take
it stretch further and it's the ability
to empathize which distinguishes an
average human being from an excellent
human being I don't know I kind of like
that so let that sit in we'll take a
trip a trip ekt break think about that I
were good cool so empathy versus
sympathy I'm going to cheat I'm gonna
play a video it's an amazing video I
can't actually say it better than this
video does so we're going to watch it
it's a video by brené Brown it's from
RSA the Royal Society of the Arts and
I'm just going to I'm not going to
introduce it any more than that so what
is empathy and why is it very different
than sympathy empathy fuels connection
sympathy drives disconnection empathy
it's a very interesting Teresa Wiseman
is a nursing scholar who studied
professions very diverse professions
where empathy is relevant and came up
with four qualities of empathy
perspective taking the ability to take
the perspective of another person or
recognize their perspective as their
truth staying out of judgment not easy
when you enjoy it as much as most of us
do
recognizing emotion and other people and
then communicating that empathy is
feeling with people and to me I always
think of empathy is this kind of sacred
space when someone's kind of in a deep
hole and they shout out from the bottom
and they say I'm stuck it's dark I'm
overwhelmed and then we look and we say
hey on down I know what it's like down
here and you're not alone sympathy is
ooh it's bad uh-huh uh no you want
sandwich if he is a choice and it's a
vulnerable choice because in order to
connect with you I have to connect with
something in myself that knows that
feeling rarely if ever does an empathic
response begin with at least I had a
yeah and we do it all the time because
you know what someone just shared
something with us that's incredibly
painful and we're trying to silver
lining it I don't think that's a verb
but I'm using it as one we're trying to
put this a little running around it so I
had a miscarriage at least you know you
can get pregnant I think my marriage is
falling apart at least you have a
marriage
John's getting kicked out of school at
least Sarah is an A student but one of
the things we do sometimes in the face
of very difficult conversations is we
try to make things better if I share
something with you that's very difficult
I'd whether you say I don't even know
what to say right now I'm just so glad
you told me because the truth is rarely
can a response make something better
what makes something better is
connection so you're going to notice
that there's a handful of things that I
kind of lifted right out of that I'm
sampling all through this talk that'll
make sure to kind of give reference so
you can see where I'm grabbing things
from one of the important things I'm
going to do here is I'm going to
constantly repeat things that I think
are really important for you to absorb
and that's if any of you ever do any
public speaking that's a really great
technique it's just repeat yourself over
and over because like I have the
attention span of like a fly so by
repeating things you can make sure that
like that important information gets out
there so as they said empathy is feeling
with you sympathy is feeling for you
empathy is about being present with
someone empathy is a choice rarely can a
response make something better what
makes something better as a connection
another trip ekt break just think about
it I love this one it's like smoke so
let's get into the history this is going
to get really really dry I'm sorry but
it's kind of cool and a spoiler believe
it or not the term empathy is only about
a hundred years old so romantic thinkers
in the 18th century such as herder in
Novalis question the contemporary notion
of aesthetics and aesthetics we're
talking about in kind of like art
history the aesthetics of art what makes
something beautiful what evokes emotion
the main problem was that of expression
if our nature are incapable of
expressing human feelings how then can
they if they're incapable of
experiencing human feelings how can they
express them how can i get like sad and
melodramatic looking at a pain
of a tree doesn't really make sense tree
doesn't feel as far as i know it works
so in 1870 to a German philosopher
Robert Fischer proposed an answer that
the explanation must lie in some
unconscious process of the person who
views these forms and I'm going to
totally mess this up actually know what
rather than me saying it on the count of
three two all the German audience
members want to say this word for me
we're going to try it okay one two three
that was awesome and this directly
translates into feeling into so if you
looked at art you would feel into the
art you would see something beautiful
you would feel into it this idea was
first elaborated by Vishal ER in his
paper dose yeah I'm going to mess that
one up to opt each form mango fool it
was I close no okay whatever aesthetic
pleasure may thus be explained as
objectified self enjoyment in which
subject and object are fused our ability
to feel into art this was further
explored by another German philosopher
Theodore lips in the aesthetic that
woman was easy he closely links our
aesthetic perception and our perception
of another embodied person as a minded
creature the nature of aesthetic empathy
is always the experience of another
human so in 1999 in 1909 the term
empathy was introduced by psychologist
Edward itchin or as a Trent as
transliteration of the german term thank
you
so another trippy kitty break I love
that one one more time I'm a bumblebee
okay so let's talk about the
neuroscience of empathy many of the
ideas i'm about to discuss came from
this talk we're not good we're not going
to watch this one it's ten minutes long
that would be super cheating it was kind
of cheating before this would be really
cheating but the slides are online I'll
tweet a link to it you should definitely
watch this video it's really cool it
builds on the ideas that I'm about to
talk about I won't spoil it anymore just
watch it it's awesome but so healthy
human brains are wired for empathy one
such phenomenon is what's known as
mirror neurons so basically the neurons
fires both when you're performing an
action and when you observe someone else
performing an action and and this is
like a little clip from that RSA Animate
video that's linked in the previous
slide so this was first discovered by
italian scientists in the 1990s giacomo
rizzolatti a neuroscientist at the
university of paramount noticed this
strange phenomenon with a monkey and
some peanuts so essentially they had
this experiment setup and the monkey was
set up to an MRI and they were watching
what happened to the monkeys brain as he
ate and so the monkey would you know
like open the pinna put in his mouth and
like all the stuff would be firing off
and they're like we're scientist this is
awesome and then something really
amazing happened one of the scientists
got really really hungry and decided
just eat a peanut in front of the monkey
well it was still connected to the MRI
and all of a sudden the monkeys neurons
that fired when he ate the peanut fired
when when the scientist ate the peanut
this is like people were like what is
wrong here like this machine is broken
but it turned out that there's this
phenomenon called mirror neurons when
you witness someone doing something you
you can like sense it the neurons fire
off you know like if I fell off the
stage right now and hit my head
everybody like a little and then I'd be
really embarrassing would suck but like
if you see someone
a spider you kind of get that crawly
feeling you know you see someone get get
hurt you feel it it were wired for this
it's really it's pretty phenomenal and
this kind of challenges a lot of early
ideas about how humans are wired how
things work a lot of how our
civilization has been built on like
these notions of selfhood of oneness of
not being connected to people that's
what this the other talk that I
reference is all about i really suggest
that you watch it but so Marco Jacoby
professor of psychiatry and I hate bio
behavioral sciences argue that neural
neurons are the neural basis of the
human capacity for emotions such as
empathy so you know again if we if we go
back to what we were talking in the
history this concept has been around for
about you know like a hundred 150 years
and now all of a sudden you know like 20
years ago we're getting research that's
showing hey you know like not only is
this like a phenomena that we can talk
about philosophically there's actually
like a scientific back background behind
this like we're wired to do this so like
some other examples that you can see is
when a baby cries in a nursery all the
other babies join in this is a
phenomenon called empathic distress so
you know we can watch the growth of
children and we can kind of see you know
around the age of two and a half a child
starts actually being able to recognize
their self in a mirror this this sense
of self pneus comes in and the sense of
selfhood goes hand in hand with an
empathic development now that they have
self they can look at others and start
like understanding you know if this
person hurts themselves I can kind of
feel it I can relate with that so the
next slide I'm going to apologize so
this first one is from the first season
of full house and I tried to find a
really good one Michelle tanner because
the next size about eight year olds but
I couldn't get an eight year-old
michelle tanner unfortunately but it's
around eight years of age a child starts
learning about birth and death they
learn about vulnerability and this
starts like really it starts with like
an existential trip you start
understanding that you only have one
life that's slowly over time the things
that you do matter and then you start
looking at other people and you think
wow those people only have one life and
we're all kind of in this struggle
together and and now you're it just
grows that empathy you start thinking
hey
that person they have their own life
it's their own thing it builds it once
you realize you only have one life you
can now feel other struggles you know
that they have their own lives you know
their struggles some philosophers such
as Schopenhauer believe that the
empathic emotions such as compassion are
possible because we're all part of a
greater ontological whole it's pretty
cool concept we're all kind of part of
one thing this again kind of goes
against a lot of what our culture has
been built upon and a lot of what our
value systems have been built upon it's
important to remember though that while
our ability is to feel empathy may be
soft wired our ability to act on it is a
learned trait I really want you to think
about that because not everyone is
naturally empathetic it can be really
really hard to make yourself vulnerable
to truly empathize with someone is not
easy and so you shouldn't feel ashamed
if you're not naturally just like the
most feely amazing person in the world
hugging everyone and feeling it
constantly this is something you have to
work on you have to you have to like
build on these natural urges so we're
going to now talk a little bit about
learning empathy so this is a great
quote from a paper on education
expressing care for another person is
not an innate ability present more
naturally in some people than others but
rather a skill that can be taught and
nurtured through a supportive
educational environment it's really
interesting as you go through some of
the literature they start talking about
the importance of empathy as a teacher
and specifically kind of the idea that
when you're teaching you shouldn't be
teaching the content you should be
teaching the feeling like at the end the
knowledge itself is not really as
important as creating whole human beings
so it turns out that for myself empathy
was something I had to learn so let's go
down a little bit of an anecdote and
let's get real for the second here this
is a young me would have been even
younger a little kid
who is my younger brother um I was a bit
of a [ __ ] like not totally I wasn't
the worst but I was very self-involved I
suffer from pretty crazy ADHD I didn't
really understand like when they talked
about at like eight years ago you start
like recognizing other people and
understanding them like that didn't
actually come naturally to me I didn't
really understand it i was super
self-involved and I was super
self-involved for quite a while so like
you know like I wasn't exactly a problem
child but I was never very observant I
went through a good chunk of my life
without having very meaningful
relationships and this is even within my
own family it was just you know
unfortunate but it's just what happened
then I met Christina so she's very
different than I am she patiently taught
me how to be observant and how to feel
for others so sharing my life with
someone made me a better person and has
made me a more empathetic person it's
important to remember well our ability
to feel empathy may be soft wired our
ability to learn it our ability to act
on it is a learned trait ask yourself
Who am I who is the other and I'm going
to ask you all if you have time to go
and look up the term other there's a lot
of really amazing philosophy about this
concept of the other and it's something
that's like hardwired into our culture
and super freaking toxic but who is this
other how are they other why are they
other how do we relate what do we share
what do they need from me and I from
them so a trippy katie break I was
really heavy
so empathy as a developer so there's
three places that we can focus on this
having empathy for the people you make
things for having empathy for those you
make things with and having empathy for
yourself which truthfully is kind of the
place you need to start because if you
don't have empathy for yourself you
can't empathize for anyone else so
having empathy for the people you make
things for how are ways that we can do
that accessibility is a really easy one
we've seen some really great talks today
about accessibility know who's using
your software know who's using your
site's care about all of them no one
user is less important than the other
there's a really really great concept
called the poor child the the idea is if
you maintain multiple code bases one of
them is just not going to be cared for
as much as the other make sure there's
no poor children make sure you care
about everyone that you're making
software for performance and bandwidth
not everyone that you're making software
for is on a brand new MacBook Pro and
living in a city with cheap data plans
think about the people around the world
who are going to be using your software
think about how to make it easy for them
empathize for them you there's tools
that are available like I think it's
called comcast fi it's really amazing it
will like slow down your internet
connection to a halt so that you can
like experience like how bad it is to be
on Comcast but no but like put these
tools into your workflow see what it's
like go on to sites that can go and give
you an idea of how much it costs to just
load your web page on a random site and
I say this as like I have this like I
think there's like 100 megabytes just to
load my slide presentation so you know
like I understand that you can't always
do it but think about it platform
support you know not everyone is going
to be on OS X not everyone is going to
be on Windows you know like a really
funny anecdote I recently was talking to
a friend of mine who I won't name the
company cuz I don't wanna get them in
trouble but so what's really really cool
is everyone thinks you know Internet
Explorer is the worst and you know I
don't want to support IE 8 turns out you
know what's going to really make our
lives really difficult
safari because because it turns out that
windows at least gives people the option
of updating their browser if you have an
old macbook like you know your
grandmother you gave her your macbook
because you're such a nice grandkid or
you gave it to your grandfather or your
cousin an old macbook actually can't
upgrade to the new OS X which means you
can't upgrade to the new safari so you
end up with all these old safaris that
have all these really weird bugs think
about that be aware of that when you
make like a really flashy splash page
for your like healthcare startup maybe
that's a bad idea build your user not
for yourself this is a huge thing I see
people doing all the time you know you
feature creep yourself with all the
amazing things you think your site could
do maybe your users just don't care
which brings us to the final one listen
to them talk to them like actually go
meet them care about them having empathy
for those you make things with
documentation is just like a no-brainer
I'm not even gonna bother talking but
you all know what I'm going to say
testing same thing just do it like let's
do it onboarding this is a really
interesting one so I helped organize a
conference called jQuery SF and there
was a really amazing talk by John rezac
who's the creator of jQuery and he
talked about empathy for for his you
know end users who were developers
working with the jQuery platform so it's
interesting too if you make developer
tools empathizing for those who make
things with is empathizing for those you
make things for it's the same person
it's also kind of empathizing for
yourself to 10 turns out they're all the
same but so he talks about onboarding
people on the first day and the first
week and the first month someone should
be able to sit down and get running
within 20 minutes without really hitting
any roadblocks then in the first week
they should be able to get running and
not really have problems to have the
documentation they need to do a basic
something and then a month like they
should have the support that's necessary
to just get things done that was one of
the first things jquery did that's why
it was so successful ray-ban go is the
first developer working on the jquery
project and he literally would go
around the entire internet and find
every single problem that anyone had
with jquery hunt them down and fix it or
at least support them first class
support was really important so think
about that when you're bringing new
employees into your office how did it
feel on your first day when you showed
up and someone handed you like a massive
rail stack was like install post grass
and you're like what's address you know
why am i posted be a good Ally and boast
in the sense of a 11 y and also in the
sense as a human being if you haven't
heard this term go Google what it means
to be an ally go Google what it means to
be a bad a lie that's a great one look
at like there's some really really great
blogs if you want to know tweet me I'll
send you some of them one of the best
things you can do to is go out and find
this out for yourself don't expect every
person from an underrepresented minority
to go and be a text book for you the
information is out there go find it
listen to them talk to them listen to
them hear what they have to say having
empathy for yourself which as I saying
was one of the most important things set
healthy boundaries be in at a certain
time be out at a certain time something
that I really enjoy doing at my last job
I'm one of those people who like if I'm
not into something I just can't do it
but the second I get like wired on it
I'll just like work non-stop and usually
that happens it like two in the morning
if you go on my github report card it's
really funny and like starts and it like
you know like eleven o'clock it goes up
and I'm like three o'clock i'm really
doing integer job and then it dumps
around like six when I go home and I
hang out with Christina and then she
usually goes to bed around eleven and
that shoots up again around two in the
morning and then it bottoms out around
like four or five so I had to deal with
my manager which was essentially hey if
I have a really really good night and
I'm really dialed in I'm going to work
and you know what I'm not coming in the
next day and it was fine because the
work got done set healthy boundaries for
yourself be honest with the people that
you work with listen to your body one
thing that I learned recently which was
really great and I'm not going to lie I
did it last night instead of staying up
all night you know what I'll do is I'll
go to sleep early and then wake up at
like five in the morning and get things
done when I'm well-rested think about
how your body is if you're hungry eat if
you're not hungry don't eat I like I
don't need to tell you that you know how
to listen be aware of imposter syndrome
it's a thing if
you haven't heard about it google it if
you have heard about it stop doing it
we're all awesome but seriously like I
mean we're all pretty amazing people
like when you actually look at how many
people are able to do what we're doing
in the world it's not many like
recognize that recognize how amazing you
are don't tear yourself down you'll be
the first person to do it listen to
yourself talk to yourself not in public
but talk to yourself okay so let's bring
it all back let's repeat everything i
said before so we can think about it
again let's hack time well we may be
soft wired for empathy the term is only
existed for about a hundred years
theresa Wiseman's defining attributes of
empathy let's go over this one more time
do people want to say it with me or is
that just weird you want to say it with
me that's cheesy I'm going to just say
it understand perspective stay out of
judgment recognize what they are feeling
and communicate it back it is important
to remember well our ability to be to
feel empathy may be soft wired our
ability to act on it is a learned trait
don't be down on yourself if you're not
naturally empathetic you you can build
on this you can learn and even if you're
not soft wired for it you can learn
you're in this room because you're good
learners you can learn empathizing
requires for you to be vulnerable that
can be scary empathy is a choice
astronaut how am I unique but rather how
are we the same feel with people rarely
can a response make something better
what makes something better is
connection maybe what you say doesn't
matter maybe the only thing that matters
in the end are the relationships that
you build thank you very much
reject